well meantime brian a local veteran who
served our country for almost 30 years
reflects on her time in afghanistan and
as victoria saha reports fears the worst
for the helpless civilians who are left
behind as the taliban seizes the country
they are images hard to believe afghan
civilians clinging to a u.s military jet
that speaks desperation rosita hicks
retired lieutenant commander nurse court
for the u.s navy was hoping this
wouldn't happen without our presence
there then all of that
goes back to
as if we were never there hicks was one
of the thousands of u.s troops sent to
afghanistan over the last 20 years to
help the afghani people be empowered
against the taliban but ultimately it
failed was able to see firsthand
some of the destructions and the life
loss and resources and et cetera
so
i am
with a lot of emotion she says while the
u.s had a presence there the civilians
felt secure but that security was
temporary as you can see in these images
of people trying to flee the country the
taliban etc
nowhere we're no longer there so but if
they just pretty much waited us out
while hicks worked as a nurse in the
local hospital she came face to face
with members of the taliban and was
forced to treat them no conversations
were allowed and she says the taliban
patients had to keep their eyes shut the
entire time so they couldn't see who was
treating them which served as an extra
layer of security for our u.s troops i
don't think i ever want to
witness that again in my lifetime and
she says there's good reason as to why
the afghani people are left fearing for
their lives you should fear that person
because they're not in fear of losing
their own lives so your life means even
less victoria saha 8 news
now powerful interview a spokesperson
for the taliban says they will respect
women's rights but hicks says she
doesn't believe that because during
their time in afghanistan women and
children were purposely injured and
treated very unfairly hicks fears this
is going to continue to happen with the
taliban's control